существует такое мнение что если вы
будете заниматься чем-то 100 часов то вы
будете лучше чем 95% людей на этой
планете и существует также второе мнение
что если вы будете заниматься чем-то
10.000 часов то вы станете буквально
мастером этого дело Давайте разберёмся
Сколько нужно потратить времени и что
нужно делать для того чтобы стать
настоящим профессионалом миф про 100
часов курсирует в интернете в виде Мема
и Многие люди думают что чно заниматься
100 часов одним делом Чтобы стать лучше
чем
95% людей на этой планете правило 10.000
часов ввёл Малкольм глад в своей книге
выдающейся где он говорит что если вы
будете заниматься каким-либо делом поле
10.000 часов то вы станете мастером
этого дела так ли это Давайте сегодня об
этом поговорим наверняка среди тех кто
сейчас смотрит это видео есть очень
много профессионалов пожалуйста напишите
в комментариях Сколько времени вы
потратили на то чтобы стать
профессионалом сго Дело это будет крайне
интересно для всех процесс обучения
чему-либо новому или процесс становления
экспертом в какой-либо сфере состоит из
нескольких этапов и нескольких стадий
которые в свою очередь характеризуются
своими особенностями и своими
определёнными вызовами эти стадии
помогают нам понять как или через Что
проходит человек на пути своего
совершенствования в какой-либо сфере на
пути совершенствования своих навыков и
знаний Давайте пройдёмся по этим стадиям
Первая стадия называется несознательный
стадия с которой начинает Любой человек
на этой стадии человек очень
замотивирован он воз
одушевлённое и он живёт предвкушения от
того что он получит когда он станет
профессионалом он ещё не видит всех
трудности барьеров препятствий и так
далее он видит только положительную
сторону того занятия котором он начал
заниматься эта стадия Когда в просто
народе называется человек ещё не знает
что он не знает и через эту стадию
проходят все И кстати сразу хочу сделать
предостережение Дело в том что на этой
стадии находится большая часть людей и
проблема этой стадии даже не в самой
этой стадии а в том что на этой стадии
люди очень часто принимают неправильные
решения на этой стадии они ещё не
осознают свою некомпетентность они
думают что они что-то знают на самом
деле они не знают то есть они не знают
что они не знают и Представьте когда
человек при на этой стадии принимает
какие-либо решения к каким
катастрофическим последствиям это может
привести поэтому само осознание того что
вы чего-то не знаете это уже уберет вас
как минимум от 50% всех ошибок которые
вы совершаете А может быть даже больше
вторая стадия называется сознательная
некомпетентность когда человек вышел из
первой стадии перел во второй уровень
сознательная некомпетентность для себя
Например я определяю что эта стадия или
Этот уровень сознательной
некомпетентности - это своеобразная
точка отсечения Я прям этот уровень так
и называю точка отсечения или Долина
смерти как правило на этой стадии 95%
людей сливаются они дальше не продолжают
потому что на этой стадии когда человек
изучает какую-либо новую область он
сталкивается с осознанием своих проблем
и с осознанием своих пробелов в своих
знаниях и навыков и он начинает видеть
сколько много надо ему Изучить и он
Таким образом он сталкивается с огромным
разочарованием с чувством неуверенности
с чувством выгорания демотивировать
продолжать идти дальше Потому что
слишком много надо сделать если привести
аналогию это знаете вот долины смерти я
обычно называю Когда вы идёте в горы это
первая треть подъёма представьте вот
поход в гору до горы вы идёте ещё по
равнение у вас небольшой подъём
небольшой Градиент вы полны энтузиазма
вы воодушевление вы замотивирован вы
живёте предвкушением того как Вы будете
делать фото селфи наверху с это с
вершины горы и как вас все друзья Вами
будут восхищаться и вас хвалить это
первая стадия вторая стадия - это когда
вы начали подниматься и идёте пер треть
горы в этот момент и результаты ваши ещё
очень слабы и вы понимаете насколько вы
не подготовлены и вы глядя вперёд на
гору понимаете как много ещё и как долго
идти и как много трудностей впереди вас
ждёт и вот здесь обычно сливается 95%
людей но в то же время те люди которые
осознали ценность своей цели на этой
стадии получают ещё больше определённой
злости мотивированности что нет я всё
равно дойду Вот это такая стадия кото
поляризуемость
раз испытывали такое состояние то
Ставьте лайк и слушайте дальше третья
стадия называется сознательная
компетентность На этом этапе человек уже
чувствует какие-то результаты если брать
аналогию с горой то Представьте это
стадия когда человек уже на середине
горы так вот на этой стадии он уже
потратил очень много усилий он потратил
очень много труда много энергии ему уже
бросать не хочется в то же время он уже
вкусил первые плоды и особенно он вкусил
Победы свои преодоления самого себя и он
уже начинает приобретать определённую
уверенность он начинает чувствовать что
он цели добьётся и он понимает что надо
двигаться дальше хотя это будет сложно
но в то же время его мотивирует та часть
половина пути которую он нашёл на этой
стадии люди тоже останавливаются но у
них теперь другая причина остановки они
очень часто останавливаются Потому что
им чувствуется что им достаточно они
просто дальше не хотят идти и А цель
которая их до этого мотивировала
перестаёт их мотивировать получается у
них как бы уже есть определённые Победы
в кармане и они не не считают себя уже
неудачниками но в то же время Дальше они
уже двигаться не хотят потому что
для них
цена достижение цели и вкус Победы уже
не так не такая большая разница и на
этой стадии очень много людей тоже
сливаются но сливаются совсем по другой
причине по причине того что они считают
что иму этого уже достаточно приведу
пример с собой например Мы в прошлом
году ходили к базовому лагерю Эвереста я
сознательно для себя Поставил цель идти
до базового лагеря но ни в коем случае
не на сам Эверест То есть мне например
достаточно было дойти до базового лагеря
Эвереста что практически там почти 6.000
МТ над уровнем моря и я вот как раз
отношусь себя к той категории людей если
брать по этой классификации А что я не
ставил себе цели зайти на Эверест я
ставил себе цель дойти до базового
лагеря это мне больше чем достаточно так
и в жизни когда вы достигаете цели очень
многие люди пройдя Вот первые две стадии
особенно вторая стадия которую я
называют Долина смерти пройдя её
приходят на эту ста
не сознательной компетентности чувствуют
первые плоды победы и говорят мне этого
достаточно А если взять например
какую-то профессиональную сферу на этой
стадии вы просто уже приобретаете
определённые навыки которые вам
достаточно для того чтобы в принципе
жить нормальной жизнью я ещё одну
аналогию приведу например Вы знаете я в
своё время когда учился пилотированию
вертолётов Я смотрел статистику
смертность и удивительно там
статистика была она още мировая что
наибольшая
смертность у пилотов - это первые 100
часов и это объяснимо это люди находятся
на самой первой стадии Вернее на второй
стадии это сознательная некомпетентность
даже сказал такая граница не
сознательная некомпетентность и
сознательная некомпетентность когда
новички они
воодушевленно вле но в то же время у них
недостаточно знаний и навыков и изза них
не знаний навыков они совершают аварии
дальше начиная со 100 часов налётов до
по часов налётов как правило аварийность
столько падает падает падает падает и
начиная с полтысячи
часов аварийность опять возрастает И
когда я изучал Выяснилось что
аварийность возрастает по одной причине
что на этой стадии А эта стадия уже
сознательная компетентность человек
считает что он уже всё знает он считает
что он уже всё умеет всё знает и может
немного баловаться и вот эта беспечность
приводит к росту аварии дальше аварии
опять падают падают падают и последний
скачок делается на когда у человека
5.000 налётов в часов я удивился Почему
такие опытные пилоты с 5.000 налётов в
часов и у них аварийность вновь
подскакивает это было связано с тем что
они перешли На четвёртую стадию которая
называется не сознательная
компетентность это когда человек
настолько всё знает что он уже делает
всё на авто включая свой мозг и
благодаря этому опытные черезчур опытные
пилоты начинают игнорировать
Элементарные правила безопасности у них
замыливание человека становятся
настолько его что они в него настолько
проникают и становятся внутренними что
это становится его второй натурой он для
того чтобы делать профессионально своё
дело Он не прилагает практических усилий
и он не включает как правило голову он
мало задумывается он больше делает это и
хорошо и плохо Как я сказал хорошо тем
что
человек делает всё на уровне там
инстинктов
а очень быстро не задумываясь но плохо о
том что очень часто это приводит к тому
что человек начинает игнорировать элемен
правила безопасности или какие-то
действия делает на автопилоте И кстати
есть ещё такой тоже хороший тест прежде
чем принимать какое-либо решение или
прежде чем заниматься особенно
какой-либо опасной или сложной
деятельностью Задайте себе вопрос На
какой стадии компетентности вы
находитесь для чего это нужно вот у меня
есть правило или алгоритм принятия
решений и в этом алгоритме принятия
решений у меня один из пунктов гласит
так чётко Определи уровень своей
компетентности то есть вот я когда
принимаю решение по какому-либо
направлению Я сначала для себя определяю
уровень своей компетентности на какой
стадии я нахожусь на стадии что я не
знаю что я не знаю либо на стадии что я
думаю что я знаю или на стадии когда я
точно знаю что знаю Кстати даю вам сразу
же хороший лайфхак для того чтобы
определить какой Специалист Или Эксперт
или сотрудник которого вы не нанимаете
на работу разбирается в вопросе или нет
сразу
посмотрите как он реагирует на задачи
которые вы ему даёте если он сразу же
приступает к выполнению не задумываясь
значит он знает А если он начинает
думать то скорее всего он ещё
недостаточно компетентен Здесь тоже
нужно вот эти учитывать нюансы То есть я
всегда Рекомендую вам Когда вы получаете
советы от любого эксперта или любого
специалиста вы также сча
начинайте с оценки уровня его
компетенций потому что будет крайне
глупо слушать чьи-либо советы И
рекомендации сначала не убедившись в его
компетентности Поэтому вот эти стадии и
этапы роста профессионализма человека
имеет сугубо практическое значение для
улучшения качества вашей жизни все эти
стадии проходят все 100% людей в
процессе наращивания своего
профессионализма Поэтому нужно это
учитывать но разные люди проходят их с
разной скоростью кто-то это проходит эти
стадии быстрее кто-то медленнее но
плюс-минус все люди примерно одинаково а
проходят эти стадии не пройдя эти стадии
не имеет значения сколько часов вы
потратили очень часто многие люди тратят
огромное количество часов не переходя из
одной стадии в другую а это происходит
потому что люди в процессе саморазвития
очень часто занимаются рутинные делами
не ведущими к росту их профессионализма
То есть у них нету стратегии
саморазвития или э нету стратегии а
наращивания своего профессионализма
Кстати о стратегии Я поговорил в
предыдущем видео обязательно посмотрите
о том что такое стратегия и как она
напрямую влияет на нашу жизнь